we have just uh insane news news
corporations Fox News is going to be
launching their own Weather Channel if
you can believe it the week is reporting
that fox is launching a weather
streaming service and it is already
feuding with the Weather Channel
Rupert Murdoch is looking to Reign on
The Weather Channel's parade there's
there's a nice line Murdoch is set to
debut a new streaming service Fox
weather this fall with his company
believing that the quote sometimes
stayed world of weather TV is ripe for
disruption the New York Times reports
Fox weather is aiming to take on the
Weather Channel but the times noted that
the latter company is already throwing
some shade at its new competitor
Weather Channel Chief content officer
Nora zimmit told the New York Times they
couldn't even get a headlight headline
right about tropical storm bill slamming
a recent article on Fox news's website
claiming the storm posed a massive
threat I applaud Fox getting into the
weather space but they should really
leave the life-saving information to the
experts that is not really the issue for
me the issue for me is is the next
aspect of this that's addressed zimmit
added that climate change is too
important to politicize and if they do
that they will be doing Americans a
disservice a fox weather spokesperson
pushed back telling the times quote
while the weather channel is focused on
trollingfoxnews.com for unrelated
stories Fox weather is busy
preparing the debut of our Innovative
platform to deliver critical coverage to
an incredibly underserved Market when I
hear that fox weather says weather is an
underserved Market when it's a third of
the nightly local news on the 6 p.m news
in basically every Market on the 11 pm
news in basically every Market if you
look at a half hour of local news those
those half hour news shows Once you take
out commercials it's 21 minutes often
six or seven of those 21 minutes are
weather a third okay and in addition to
that you have the Weather Channel
in addition to that everybody on their
phones has constant live weather and
when there are notable weather events
the major cable networks like MSNBC CNN
and fox cover weather so when I hear Fox
weather say
that weather is underserved what I'm
hearing is there's not enough climate
denial presented as science and and
packaged as if it is the Weather Channel
and that is what I fundamentally believe
that this is about they make billions by
uh uh playing political theater stoking
polarization stoking gridlock allowing
the people who say Trump really won and
all of this stuff to just appear on
their Network they build that up and
then they build themselves up as the
ones who will tell you the truth why am
I not seeing on the other networks that
Trump actually won well maybe it's
because Trump didn't really win no it's
because nobody but Fox will tell me the
truth that's the ideology and the
attitude that they sort of stoke
um In Their audience and with a fair
amount of climate denial right remember
the clips from Fox News despite it being
bitterly cold in the winter
in North Dakota in DC Democrats are
talking about climate change those types
of headlines so they've got the perfect
audience for it and now they will
smoothly make the switch and say hey
we'll also tell you the truth about the
weather and climate which are actually
two different things come on over uh
this is what they are planning in a
sense it's brilliant it's Evil Genius I
guess is what I would call it weather is
going to become a ratings maker in the
sense that it will now be a proud and
defiant alternative to the fake news
weather that the meteorologists on the
Weather Channel and elsewhere are giving
you it if it weren't so obviously going
to work it would be worth laughing at
but because it's probably going to work
it's actually the type of thing we
should be crying over creating an
alternative narrative
that climate deniers can point to and
say no no no no no no
Fox weather has a different perspective
on this it's extraordinarily dangerous
and it will be launching in a few months
and I am uh genuinely horrified by what
this what this may do because remember
the there is a virus in the U.S which is
people don't even understand what are
facts and whenever I say that it sounds
like I'm using strange syntax because
people assume I'm saying people don't
understand what the facts are no no no
no it's worse people no longer
understand what are facts what types of
statement are empirical statements
statements based on the scientific
method for example
versus what are just opinions and when
you don't understand what is a fact and
what is an opinion which is what Fox
News specializes in all hell breaks
loose apply that deranged system to
weather now and it is a recipe for
absolute and total disaster uh I don't
think I'm being uh exaggerated in how
dangerous this is but I want to hear
from you you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman and let me know your thoughts
for the longest time I was having
trouble finding snacks that are healthy
but actually taste great and fill me up
and satisfy a craving and that's why
it's great that I stumbled upon monk
pack and we asked them to be one of our
sponsors monk pack keto nut and Seed
bars are delicious snacks that have one
gram of sugar or less only two to three
grams of net carbs and just 150 calories
perfect for a keto or low carb diet or
anybody who like me just prefers to eat
a low sugar diet I love the monk pack
keto nut and Seed bars because it's
really just a great balance of sweet and
salty soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and Seeds flavors
include caramel or caramel you tell me
sea salt sea salt dark chocolate and
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
favorite they'll give you all of your
money back if you don't love it go to
monkpak.com the link is down below and
they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code Pacman